tigers have matt boyd on the mound today
two and three
see the area is excellent
you know when matt boyd first came over
here we're thinking this guy throws
pretty good we're looking at the velo
now all of a sudden
he's throwing twice as many change-ups
as sliders and fastballs he's kind of
settling in a very good one
he did that at his last start
and that's a key pitch against righties
strike three called
a nice start for matthew boyd on this
sunday
little backdoor slider
through the changeup and way off
contraries thought here it comes again
and it went the other way right on the
edge of the plate
first pitch was inside he tried to spin
on it he thought boyd was going away and
he came in
and he struck him out
that's the first time rizzo has struck
out in his last 25 played appearances
shaking his head after an eight pitch
first for matthew boyd starting for the
cubs this afternoon is kyle hendricks
check in with the professor
86 mile an hour sinker change up
occasional force seamer that he likes to
elevate and the curve ball
to two
inside corner see you later grossman is
gone cubs and the clubs are wearing
camouflage caps
hit on the ground duffy they go to
second for one return to first and they
turn it well done
hendrick shaking his head five six three
gets help from the defense into one no
score
that's two and two to baez who is two
for seven with a double in the series
that double came last
night swung on and missed third
strikeout already of the day for matthew
boyd he starts the second like he did
the first
there it is to right center field
mazzara dives and
makes the catch
full superman layout and no mar mazzara
robs matt duffy
of extra bases good d there
gets a good jump he's got a beat on it
you saw this yesterday
got that glove out to the side
that gives you an opportunity to make a
last
few steps adjustment with your hands
and look at duffy you kidding me do you
catch that
chris bryant swung at the first pitch
his first time boyd has thrown eight of
ten first pitch strikes
off the end of the bat softly hit castro
to goodrum return to first not in time
coming home and in to score is half
aggressive base running from ian happ
and the cubs are on the board one zip
so brian able to leg it out and he
inhabited
showing off the wheels there
a little backhand flip there to second
base he can have never stopped
and a hurried throw is an errant throw
probably had time scope did to take a
step and make a more accurate throw and
they still would have had a play on him
another row two there it is and he
punches him out for the second time
today
chicago scores a run they have the early
lead
we'll film it don't worry
[Applause]
17 straight games jacoby jones has
struck out hendricks
punches him out second strikeout today
got him all nicely done
it was close earlier and he's able to
pick off willy castro yeah again castro
was leaning and perfectly timed by
hendricks who gets another one and this
will give us a really good look at it
anthony lets that ball travel
strike three call and the inning is over
hendrick strikes out grossman
we go to inning number four
all right here's ian happ
the stretch by the left-hander boyd
ian batting right-handed pops it up
shallow center going out and unable to
make the play is the shortstop a run is
going to score duffy comes in to score
racing to second safely as happ on the
play going to third as nico horner cubs
lead two-nothing a blooper into shallow
center falls in because if he really
wanted to bunt that would have been a
good pitch to bump right
all right just wanted to work through
that in my mind
right there mazara
strikes out looking and kyle hendricks
did a pretty good groove he has struck
out four here today
aj hinch likes those catchers and you
understand why they've been really good
at receiving two matthew boyd really
good at dealing strikes out chris bryant
to start the chicago fifth upright
stance knees slightly flexed tucks that
left shoulder in just a little bit
swinging a miss fastball up three times
in a row matthew boyd has dispatched
javier baez with a high fastball the
average
time that you have to wait between
pitches in major league baseball today
is about 23 seconds between pitches 30
plus seconds if guys are on base not
with hendricks here comes the 02.
calls strike three on the outside corner
a one two three fifth for hendricks and
the cubs and now it's david bode who's
old for two
[Applause]
hit hard fair ball down the line and off
the sidewall
racing for third is duffy he's coming
around here's the throw to the plate and
that's too late and ending up at third
is david bode it's three nothings
[Applause]
in the air out towards right center
mazara will make the catch tagging at
third is bodhi and it comes at a run
nikko horner is sac fly and it's four
nothing sixth inning two down bases
empty the pitch to hamp hamp drives one
in the air to deep right field this is
back toward the wall it's got a chance
gone
opposite field home run ian happ cubs
lead five nothing he let that pitch get
to him and get deep on the plate and
then just pounds this ball the other way
caught him looking
back in the third
got him to swing and miss there that was
the curveball it's a half dozen
strikeouts now
for kyle hendricks
and the pitch to castro swinging a
roller to the right side glove by horner
on the outfield grass good play throws
to rizzo to get him owner a sliding stop
he was 15 to 20 feet beyond the infield
dirt and shallow right kyle hendricks is
cruising
in detroit well here's a bouncer to
horner in shallow right gloves it throws
to first to get him kyle hendricks with
seven shutout innings under his belt as
he walks off toward the cubs first base
dugout the longest start by any cub
hurler and jacoby jones will come up
that's on the outside corner got him
looking jones frustrated he's gone for
the third time today
strike three call grossman caught
looking hendricks rolling along eight
shutout innings we go to the ninth cubs
five tigers nothing bottom of the ninth
and kyle hendricks will continue and try
and finish it off
on the ground and knacks into center
field for a base hit yeah david ross is
coming out and it looks like
he will make the move to kyle hendricks
end of the road
and a great great effort from the
right-handers one with a k-1 with a c
and another k
to end the ball game cubs won it 5-1 as
winkler fans goodrum